The fourth major concept in evolutionary
biology that is really critical for
understanding how to think about medical
problems is adaptation and adaptation
is a concept that has been problematic
and it needs special attention,
but we also need to understand how
do we recognize when something isn't
adaptation?
Okay,
why is it problematic?
Well,
adaptation is the central
character in just so stories.
These are often coupled to some imaginary
environment and the evolutionary past
that has just precisely the
characteristics needed to make a favorite
hypothesis.
Plausible.
We shouldn't believe such stories and
if that is the only basis for calling
something an adaptation,
well you can forget it,
claims it out of adaptations should
therefore not be accepted unexamined.
Any hypothesis of adaptation needs
to be tested against alternatives.
Evolutionary biologists have devoted
quite a bit of thought to this and they've
developed several criteria
for recognizing adaptations.
So here are some of them
natural selection itself,
if you can observe it.
Perturbation criteria and the functional
criteria and the design criterion and
the invasion resistance criteria.
So we'll step through those
to see what they mean.
Natural selection itself.
Now natural selection on a trait is
we've seen exists given a correlation
between variation in the tree and
variation in reproductive success,
a response occurs when some of the
variation in the traits heritable.
So if you can document heritable
changes in the trait that result from a
demonstrate and correlation of treat
Steve With reproductive success,
then you've pretty much nailed it.
You've watched natural selection in
action and the many cases of experimental
evolution are cases in
which that has been done.
So in a case like that,
the adaptation is the change in the tree.
It's not the ground state of the trade.
The adaptation is the amount of change
that's occurred because of the observed
selection.
Okay.
The second criterion is
the perturbation criteria.
So for that you need both a
predictive model and an experiment.
The adaptation is then the state of the
trade that's predicted by a model that's
tested and confirmed by using some method
to perturb the phenotype out of its
optimal state and to demonstrate that
the fitness of the perturbed phenotype is
lower than the fitness
of the predicted one.
This is not easy to do on humans,
but it can be done with
clutch size experiments in
birds and one of the best was
done by Dutch biologists
working on kestrels.
So here is a Kestrel and these biologists
who are working in the northern part
of the Netherlands manipulated clutch
size and measured reproductive success.
They had reduced control and enlarged
clutches and these are the sample sizes.
The number of baby birds that were fledged
coming out of the reduced clutch was
2.6 on average and nearly six 5.8
in the [inaudible] in large clutch.
And if you ask what's the reproductive
value of that clutch, in other words,
how many grandchildren are going to
result from having a clutch that size?
Well, the enlarge clutch was producing
nearly seven and the reduced clutch was
producing about three so based on that,
it would seem like it would pay
kestrels to lay more eggs. However,
look at what happens with the parents.
The local survival of the parents with
the reduced clutches is about 65% 0.65
per year,
but it's only about 43% 0.4 to nine
per year for the enlarge clutches.
As a result,
the reproductive value of the parents,
the number of offspring they would
expect to have from that point on,
including this clutch is about 10 for
the reduced clutches and it's only about
6.7 for the enlarge clutches.
So the total value,
the total reproductive value of having
reduced clutch is about one full
offspring below that
of the control clutch.
And the reproductive value of the
enlarge clutch is about half an offspring
below.
What this means is that kestrels no the
right number of offspring to have that
is determined by a trade off between the
number of offspring that they have and
their search,
their own survival,
and the result is that we can call
their clutch and adaptation by the
perturbation criteria.
The third criterion is the functional
criterion and it defines adaptation is
inappropriate plastic response.
So under this definition and adaptation
is the change in a phenotype that occurs
in response to a specific environmental
signal and it has a clear functional
relationship to that signal that results
in an improvement in growth, survival,
or reproduction.
Otherwise it doesn't appear and it
doesn't appear because it's costly.
So it is a change that is produced
only when it pays to produce it.
Here are some pretty convincing cases,
is a waterfally Daphnia,
which is the first one
Daphne will develop spines,
a longer tail spine,
and it will develop a helmet on the top
of its head in the presence of dissolved
molecules associated with predators
whose efficacy is reduced by spines and
helmets. They have a reproductive cost
and they're not produced in the absence of
predators. Daphnia producing
spines and helmets lay fewer eggs.
Here are the eggs,
Vince shells and barnacles and make
them resistant to snail predators,
but they reduced their fecundity.
Same cost benefit analysis snails
that are Paris attired by castrating,
diagenetic trematodes,
just to some myosis reproduce earlier.
So these are all convincing cases.
They are induced responses.
Okay.
The fourth criterion for
adaptation is the design criteria.
Adaptation can be recognized by its
complexity and its conformity to some op
priori design specification.
In other words,
by its resemblance to something
that an engineer might design,
any complex organ that performs
a difficult function efficiently
can therefore be thought to be an
adaptation by the design criterion.
For example,
the human eye,
when dark adapted can detect the arrival
of photons that are produced by a
single match at a
distance of 10 kilometers
that is doing something
efficiently with a complex Oregon.
That is a difficult task and that is
why sailors in wartime do not strike
matches when they're out on board ship
because they can be seen by a submarine
at a distance of 10 kilometers.
Now
to judge such claims of adaptation
by the design criterion,
George Lauder came up with five questions.
The first is have any experiments
done to support the claim function?
Does it really have that function?
Second,
has the performance of the
trait in fulfilling that
function been compared with
alternative states?
So can you actually find variation that
would allow you as with the kestrels to
look at alternatives and see
what the fitness result was?
Does the phylogenetic analysis suggests
that the state that's claimed to be an
adaptation is repeatedly associated with
the kind of natural selection that's
needed to produce it?
Could the trade have been to this state
is a byproduct of selection for some
other trait? In other words, are you
actually asking the right question?
Are you really looking at the thing
under selection? And then finally,
is it a spandrel?
And by that we mean might the claim
of adaptation be confounded by an
inappropriate abstraction of just a piece
of the organism from the larger hole
in which it's embedded. An example
of the spandrel might be the chin,
the Chin on a human may simply result
from the fact that the human face has been
reshaped by selection since our chimpanzee
ancestors to be a bit more vertical.
And that brings out a piece of bone that
looks like a chin functions as a chin,
but it may simply be part of the
reforming of the entire head.
So the number of those criteria that are
satisfied as a measure of how well the
claim of design has been confirmed.
Yeah.
Then the final criterion is the uh,
evolutionary stable strategy.
Ess Or invasion resistance criterion.
So think of a population with a trait.
This candidate for being an
adaptation to test that claim,
allow the population to be systematically
and repeatedly invaded by all possible
alternative states. Have that trait
in all orders and combinations.
So this is the kind of thing
you could do on a computer
if the candidate adaptation can resist
invasion by alternative states than we
can say that it is an adaptation in the
sense of being an evolutionarily stable
strategy that resists invasion.
Now,
that's a pretty good logical
criteria and it's a pretty tough one,
but it doesn't cover all cases.
For example,
if a beats B beets see beets a,
then you get an eternal cycle.
That is what happens in the rock paper,
scissors game.
Okay.
The state that resists all invasion,
all invaders might not be attainable
in phenotype space. In other words,
there might be a constraint in the system
such that the resistant phenotype is
not something that you can get
to starting from low frequency.
Another possibility is that there's
negative frequency dependence and that
yields and adapted set of phenotypes
rather than a single best adapted
phenotype.
In other words,
the stable state of the population is a
mixture of things rather than a single
thing.
Yeah.
Cases where the invasion challenge is
hard to arrange and the ability to resist
invasion have not been
convincingly tested,
won't be covered by this criteria.
It's a rather criteria and to fulfill.
So the summary on adaptation is that net,
when you observe natural selection,
that is the best demonstration
that something isn't.
Adaptation.
Perturbation is also quite
convincing function well in their,
in that case the induced responses are
convincing to Daphne a helmet sort of
thing.
The design claim is plausible if
Lauder's questions are answered.
And there are some things which are so
intricately and efficiently designed in
biology that it's almost perverse
not to claim that their adaptations,
the invasion, Kristen's criterion
is logically in extremely good one,
but it's only as good as the
mutations that are actually tried.
And it's rather difficult
to arrange experimentally.
So that is the summary on
a critique of adaptation.
And the bottom line is that adaptation
is only problematic if it's not tested or
if it's not testable.
One should be wary of
untestable claims of adaptation.
And this is one of those areas of science
in which in which one needs to develop
the willingness to remain agnostic
if you cannot produce good evidence.
Okay.